We now have video of Marjorie Taylor Green,
this new wacky Republican Congresswoman Kuhnen,
congresswoman of Jewish Space, Lazar's fame.
There is video of her from a week before Election
Day.
She sat down with a pro-gun activist named
Chris Dorje.
This was broadcast on Facebook from a Pennsylvania
gun shop.
And this is a 22 minute interview posted by
the Pennsylvania Firearms Association and
Marjorie Taylor Green and the gun shop owner
I'm sorry, the gun activist at the gun shop
talked about the Second Amendment, how important
it is to back Donald Trump, how important
it is to back other far right Republicans
in the election.
And Green warned that socialists must be fended
off socialists like Joe Biden, who I can't
imagine anything socially.
I can't remember a single socialist idea Joe
Biden has put forward.
They would take everybody's guns and on and
on.
And she appeared to support political violence
by saying, you only get your freedoms back
with the price of blood.
That's the key part.
And we'll look at a little bit of this beyond
that.
But that key part about the price of blood
is right at the beginning.
But here's the deal.
If this generation doesn't stand up and defend
freedom, it's gone.
Yeah.
And once it's gone, freedom doesn't come back
by itself.
The only way you get your freedoms back is
that it's earned with the price of blood.
We can't be too busy or too complacent or
too worried about offending someone anymore.
It's there's no more excuses.
This is this is it.
November 3rd.
Freedom is on the ballot.
You have a choice of either voting for freedom
by voting for Donald J. Trump for president
again for four more years, voting Republican
straight down your ballot, or you're going
to vote for socialism and vote to completely
end America as we know it.
And this is this is no joke.
They do not want you to be able to defend
yourself, because if you can defend yourself,
guess what?
Then you can stop a tyrannical government.
However, if they take away your guns, then
you can't not only can you never stop a tyrannical
government, you can never even defend yourself
if someone is breaking in your home.
And that's the reality.
This is where we are today in twenty twenty.
So freedom comes back only with the price
of blood.
They I guess Democrats don't want you to be
able to defend yourself so supportive of violence
to achieve political goals.
And then also in another prior clip on 9/11
claims there is no evidence that a plane actually
crashed into the Pentagon on 9/11, a unfortunately
relatively significantly repeated conspiracy
theory.
Here is Marjorie Taylor Green, a literal 9/11
truth her now in the House of Representatives.
Barack Obama becomes president in 2008.
OK, by that time in our American history,
we had had George Bush for eight years.
We 9/11, the sorry about that guys call came
in.
So I had to decline it on.
But we had witnessed 9/11, right?
We had witnessed 9/11, the terrorist attack
in New York and the plane that crashed in
Pennsylvania and the so-called plane that
crashed into the Pentagon.
It's odd there's never any evidence shown
for a plane and the Pentagon.
But anyways, I won't I'm not going to dove
into the 9/11 conspiracy.
She won't dove into it.
She'll merely mention it offhandedly.
Oh, OK.
All right.
This is a certifiably sick woman.
Don't we need to be giving psych eval to run
for Congress?
Don't don't we need to do something?
Create some.
Basic battery of tests for establishing a
fundamental basic level of fitness to be a
member of the House of Representatives or
the U.S. Senate, but of course, the problem
isn't just the candidates.
And I know that many of you will often focus
only on one side or the other.
Yes, the fact that Marjorie Taylor Green is
a candidate is a problem.
But if nobody was willing to vote for her,
we wouldn't be needing to worry about it.
I've said this about Trump.
If no one fell for Trump, if the Republican
primary voters weren't wacky enough to fall
for Trump, Trump saying I'm running wouldn't
really matter.
The bigger problem is that so many people
said, yes, this is who I'm choosing.
And I know that there are some who will say,
well, it's because the Democrats didn't put
up something better.
No, no, no, the Democrats did.
The Democrats may not have put up exactly
what we wanted, but the Democrats put up something
better.
And the problem is really bigger than any
one thing.
I was thinking back yesterday as I was preparing
this story.
Remember when Sarah Palin was the craziest
person in the Republican Party?
Things have escalated very, very quickly.
And I don't know why Marjorie Taylor Green
remains in Congress even one more minute.
Every Republican lawmaker should be put on
camera and asked, why don't these comments
warrant an immediate expulsion from the House
of Representatives?
On the bonus show today, we'll be talking
about why it's not even likely she will be
expelled, expelled, maybe censured, but very
unlikely to be expelled.